[Musique]
voir les enfants pour fou
patron il me tarde de savoir comment
notre petits cornichons a passé la
journée et bien et sent vite mon gros
nounours sitôt dit sitôt fait ma petit
déjeune
à tout de suite à trop
[Musique]
salée
salut il prépare son petit déjeuner pour
demain matin c'est de la fois oui
l'avoine comme dada et du miel comme
nounours à tartines j'aime pas les
tartines moi le matin je mange toujours
dans ma copine mais vous savez que de la
voix mais du miel ce doit être sue culot
tient gouttes nounours
[Musique]
ce vraiment en pot on dirait les
recettes de ma soeur emilie à
chérie
je vais t'aider cornichons ouais
j'aime mieux préparer mon petit déjeuner
tout seul
on lave t'as pas tout nous donne moi ma
cuillère bon
aux
cornichons tu es venu
[Musique]
lors du show
tu vas t'en rue mais t'inquiète pas dans
la forêt je suis toujours pieds nus
noisy à la classe mais ça me toujours
pieds nus s'est amusé à mettre un pied
ni et bien il est l'heure d'aller au lit
à présent cornichons penta salle de bain
nicolas et pimprenelle je vous
accompagne
salut salut
et de brun vous aiderez votre ami
corniche on a retrouvé ses souliers il a
déjà mis de l'ordre aujourd'hui on
s'amuse bien avec lui et qui sait ce que
nicole avena 9 n'ont quà la
[Musique]
commission dalo en dormez-vous vite que
toi aussi
où est-il pas sûr
cornichons
mois
hossa alors ce soir tu dors dans la
cuisine avec ta toupine on sait jamais
s'il y avait des souris
bonne nuit corniche au salut
salut
salut les p'tits
mecs bourrés
[Musique]
vous
alors ne nous trouvent à bien à
merveille patron et vous savez
cornichons fait de la très bonne cuisine
il est très intelligent ce petit gros
gourmand va allons en route bonne nuit
les enfants fait beau rêve salut
[Musique]